Well,
I understand that the New York fed is at
the vortex of all the regulation that is
supposed to occur with respect to banks.
The New York Fed is the least node,
but most important regulatory body out
there.
It oversees all the financial
institutions,
controls,
access to borrowing for these
institutions and actually has,
has individuals from the New York fed
present at each of the bags so it can
see and hear and feel what's going on in
the marketplace and yet it failed abject
late to see what was going on in terms
of leverage,
in terms of risk exposure,
et cetera.
Now this is all while Tim Geithner was
president of the New York fed and Tim
Geithner said when he was being
confirmed for treasury secretary,
he had never been a regulator,
which should have been not just a flare,
it should have been an exploding missile
saying this guy didn't understand his
job and I think he has failed as
treasury secretary is a consequence.
Put that aside for a moment.
The Aig Tobacco and the bailout of Aig,
where $180 billion of tax money was
funneled through Aig.
Much of it then being passed through aig
to the counter parties.
Everybody from Goldman Sachs on down or
given 100 cents on the dollar on credit
default swaps they had bought from Aig
for no apparent reason.
Goldman was given a check for 12 point
$9 billion,
which is parenthetically just about
precisely the profit they booked last
year.
Calendar Year Oh nine so the entirety of
Goldman's profit you can think of as a
tax payer and fusion.
Why did we give that to them now?
Geitner and blankfein would say because
we were owed oded,
why?
No,
there's what possible reason was there
for taxpayers to give Goldman Sachs that
money.
I want to see what their conversation
was back and forth.
Would Goldman have failed absent that in
fusion?
Did we negotiate with Goldman in return
and get stock,
get warrants?
Did we negotiate the amount of the
payment?
Why a hundred cents on the dollar?
All sorts of other people have been
taken huge financial hits.
Why did Goldman get paid off?
There are many,
many areas of inquiry that would be
exposed and would be explained if we
could break through and see aig is
emails radiating out into the regulatory
and financial sector.
Let me make it clear.
I don't think Tim Geitner is a bad
person by any stretch of the imagination
as he's,
he's not corrupt.
He's not taking bags of cash.
He's,
he's not morally in any way suspect.
He's just wrong.
And as I say,
there's no crime in being wrong.
We are all wrong,
uh,
at one point or another in varying
degrees.
And I'm certainly in that category as
well,
is as everybody knows.
And so he was wrong.
And so when I say he failed his treasury
secretary,
it has failed as treasury secretary and
is president of the New York Fed.
It's because he did not bring the right
set of principles and an understanding
of what his regulatory role was supposed
to be.
He embraced the Alan Greenspan worldview
of let them do what they want because
the marketplace,
somehow we'll provide a magic answer.
And that I think is the intellectual
error that,
that he has committed along with Larry
Summers and again,
extraordinarily smart,
brilliant individual but just wrong.
And you know,
there's no crime in being wrong,
but I think that they've taken us to a
point in terms of economic policy that
is not good and we have all paid a price
in terms of the cataclysm of the past
two years.
Understand that when the meltdown
occurred.
And so let's begin at the point of the
meltdown prior to the meltdown,
to give you a quick answer on that,
leverage was completely out of control
there.
There should have been dramatic
limitations in a,
in back of leverage.
There should have been a redefinition of
what banks that had access to the
federal window,
Federal Reserve Window in terms of tax
gain,
gaining access to federal guarantees in
actual cash could do with that money.
And that's prospectively as well.
So retrospectively they failed to
control that,
the leverage and the risk that was
coursing through the system.
And that's why we refer to it as
systemic risk prospectively.
The fundamental reform we need and put,
thankfully the president has now begun
to listen to Paul Volcker much more than
to Tim Geithner and Larry Summers on
this.
We're beginning to say to banks,
we will know no longer permit you to ask
taxpayers to cover the downside while
you keep the upside.
It knows the asymmetry between risk and
reward is what led to the massive
overleveraging and overexposure of the
system.
It's what we would have called it
somebody else's line,
not mine.
We've socialized risk and privatized
gain and anytime I can play with a huge
pile of money and if I lose,
it's your problem.
But if I win,
I keep the upside.
Of course I'm going to get involved in
much riskier investments than I should
and so we need to correct that balance.
Scale back the leverage.
Tell the banks do what banks are
supposed to do.
If you want access to federal dollars to
d guaranteed deposits,
lend that money to people who will
create jobs,
who will be businesses borrowing to
expand rather than using it for either
hedge funds,
private equity investments,
proprietary trading,
the sorts of endeavors that create great
risk through the system.
So that is one structural issue,
which the president has now begun to
focus on,
whether it's post Massachusetts and post
political,
uh,
you know,
melt down or not,
doesn't really matter to me.
He's now getting that right.
And I'm hoping that Geitner and summers
or having their wings clipped too,
because they're the ones who were not
articulating for the president.
The obligation to put that sort of
reform in place.